and action
as we were making the Creator
AI has gotten better and better and it
feels like we're at that Tipping Point
now and this movie questions what does
that look like 50 years from now when AI
is more embedded as part of society
did you locate the weapon yeah
it's a kid
guy that's really clever in how he's
built this world everything he feels
very organic and very grounded the way
we wanted to approach AI in this film
was as naturalistic as possible whether
it be the stimulants or our robots we
found a really lovely balance being able
to show the tech but also show that they
think for themselves they have feelings
I do one with the truth it was massively
ambitious but girls are directed with an
absolute Vision this film will challenge
what you believe it's hard to know whose
side to be on they've come for me
I don't think anyone's ever seen
anything like this seatbelt
it deals with what does it mean to be
human what does it mean to be alive and
can love kind of transcend those divides
those ideas are at the heart of this
film and it's not an easy thing to
answer
man confirmed it's been a pleasure to
serve you launch
foreign
[Music]